ambiance feutrée théâtre départemental
de champ fleuri
le soleil se couche et des visages
connus apparaissent web est tiré de
cause et bien soit assurée ce soir nous
allons ouvrir une exposition intel sur
les rois et les reines ils sont à côté
de nous et c'est peut-être qui mérite
d'être applaudi
j'espère qu'on va commencer je souhaite
qu'on les interdise tout de suite de
leur vivant le conseil départemental a
souhaité honorer ses rois et reines de
cette partie de la culture réunionnaise
et cela lors de l'anniversaire des 70
ans de la départementalisation
lorsque l'exposition s'ouvre enfin au
public la reconnaissance de celui qu'on
connaît guide les pas dans les allées
l'expo se visite dans tous les sens les
gens effectivement en ont pris
possession mais alors vraiment dans tous
les sens et la soirée après ce qui se
déroule sur scène les dalons carrousel
c'est aussi dans tous les sens
donc oui c'est la soirée dans tous les
sens j'aime bien tellement de choses
peut-être la première dans le temps
puisque la première personne la première
rencontre c'est firmin viry et la
première anecdote avec lui c'est celle
me regardant à l'horizon et qui me donne
lui explique pourquoi on faisait ça ce
que je voulais faire et qui me dit je
fais ça pour mes parents il serait très
fier ce petit bonhomme de 80 ans qui
veut dire je fais ça pour mes parents je
serai très fier en regardant la ligne
d'horizon
c'est ce qui a donné la photo ouais
c'est ce qui m'a vraiment donné envie de
continuer est ce déjà vous pensé de la
photo elle est belle je me demande si
c'est moi ça a l'air d'une ado ça allait
à des thunes africaine un d'ailleurs que
je suis en métropole depuis l'africaine
pour 10 à 12h oui mon père et ma photo
à peine les premières observations et
c'est alors le temps de les changes mais
surtout de l'enchantement poussoir
immense et surtout un partage l'immense
et moi ça touche tous les réunionnais
parce que tous ces personnages on les a
entendus
les a rencontrés il faut partir vraiment
de notre virée une grève accompagné de
toutes les photos des mots comme des
notes de musique viennent mettre du
relief sur ces visages passionné est
marqué par la vie le trouver au maloya
dans le maloya le maloya est
indissociable de ma vie je sais que vous
ne pouvez pas comprendre cela
si je ne vous dis pas que j'étais dans
les champs dès l'âge de 12 ans c'est à
l'invitation tout bon texte a écrit
c'est une invitation à connaître tout ça
est bonne non parce que nous la
rencontre bonne route incroyable et
c'est parce que nous connais pas qui
s'abat naïve et qu'aujourd'hui nous dit
nous les petits les files et casques à
ses allées whaou
noonan a grandi moon dans mon pays quand
robin gars comme ça dans la vie des rois
et des reines qui le son de leur vivant
et qui le reste après l'idée cette
exposition est née liane dans la
mentalité d'un pique nique
parce que les talons les terres en
hommage à
chanter a disparu et est naze et de
l'a10 tv nous aussi de mer où ça allait
les cons ça nous fait si grave la
mémoire tout ça et en plus l'idée est de
faire un super spectacle et de faire un
super album avec deux couteaux et là des
têtes c est parce qu il était hors de
question de faire simple les dalons
carrousel comme ils aiment s'appeler ont
donné un spectacle ce soir là
alors je sais que ça a dû vous ramener
quelques années en arrière du temps on
était tout simplement beau depuis
cinquante soixante ans pour enregistrer
les disques des alliés n'a la photo le
chantait agi la pochette san habite dans
l'os fartage ans loos bourricot slow
food pack ouais c'était des musiciens
qui changeait non s'il n'y avait pas eu
ces musiciens diama pichal là n'aurait
été avec date d'aujourd'hui jusqu'au 5
juin ses dix neuf figures artisans de
notre culture commune seront visibles
dans le hall du théâtre champ fleuri
d'ici là une solution pour cultiver ce
patrimoine et de chanter et danser fait